hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht es wahrscheinlich schon
im titel eingeblendet heute startet bald
ihr seht es gar nicht eingeblendet ich
bin auf der einen seite max face kam es
auf der anderen seite wie ok kommen wir
mal ein bisschen runter leute was machen
wir hier warum geht was ist minecraft
minecraft maus ist ein in minecraft
projekt leute ob ihr es glaubt oder
nicht minecraft ist in minecraft projekt
aber nicht irgendeins denn wir spielen
nicht nur langweilig minecraft nein die
haben sowohl in game minecraft
challenges wir wollen in folge 10 das
end meistern was jetzt hält das war
nicht mit mir abgesprochen dass auch
viel viel wichtiger ist wir machen die
heftigsten in game stellen wir machen
jede folge eine neue challenge in diesem
projekt und das unterscheidet es nämlich
von irgendwelchen anderen komischen
minecraft projekt noch dieser welt wir
fangen schon mal an uns holz zu holen
ich hab schon holz ich hab mir schon ich
habe schon ich hab' ich hab' ich hab'
ich habe schon drei holz haben erfolg
viele fragen sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
auch hey die larven was mit challenges
was ist denn die erste challenge max die
erste tänzer lieber luca ist dass du
wann immer ich dir sage eine
liegestützen machen oder sagen wir nicht
einiges gesagt wann immer ich dir sage
mach mal zehn liegestützen wie wärs denn
wo läuft überhaupt gar nicht hin da
hinten der vorne gibt's stein und zum
gebirge kommen einfach man also die
challenge ist heute das immer wenn max
das will machen ich quasi zehn
liegestütze und werde das dann quasi
hinter mir irgendwie hintergrund
vollziehen gesetz wahrscheinlich schon
wir haben schilder installiert deswegen
habe ich noch externe fackel geholt ich
das machen dass ich mega cool aus hier
mit dem wie du hast du wieder ich habe
die ganze zeit tut mir leid man kein
ding älter es sieht viel zu geil auf mit
dem china was leute wir laufen mal ganz
kurz zusammen zu dem wasser hält
der schwede was luca bevor ich jetzt
hier zu sehr freies macht sie mir bitte
mal zehn liegestützen und films das
ganze mit deinem iphone dass viele heute
noch sehen können kann ich einfach in
der fei scam zeigen wenn die leute dann
sehen kann wie es mir wichtig dass alles
sehen können wie du dich zum affen macht
laut mit zehn locker machen die changes
immer abwechselnd immer in der folge von
demjenigen der gerade auf lebt muss er
die challenge machen und meine nächste
challenge wird mindestens genauso
schlimm für mich ich werde nämlich
wasabi essen müssen genau leute das
heißt falls ihr es falls wir es jetzt
noch nicht so wirklich gesagt haben die
folgen werden abwechselnd auf unseren
beiden kanälen hochgeladen werden das
heißt habe ich gerade garnelen oder
kanälen gesagt ich weiß es nicht ich
muss ja irgendwie von garnelen denken
weil ich über hunger habe die folgenden
abwechselnd auf unseren beiden kanälen
hochgeladen das heißt die erste folge
ist wie es gerade sieht bei mir die
zweite folge wird bei mag sein das heißt
ihr könnt schon mal fleißig max
abonnieren der hat hast du schon 5000
enten zu dem zeitpunkt vielleicht ja es
könnte gut sein dass ich sie gerade
geknackt habe auf jeden fall richtig
richtig kann so happy wir das in der
letzten zeit läuft und wir haben uns
auch eigentlich erst gedacht dass wir
dieses projekt mit minecraft exit machen
und wir haben das schon gestern abend
aufgenommen und haben uns schon tokios
geholt und wollten dann mit denen
rumreiten und so aber es waren so viele
bugs und dann sind die chocobos verpackt
ist abgestürzt immer und deswegen jetzt
gesagt minecraft vanilla ja aber das
halten wir ein wirklich eure wegen
gemacht weil es macht einfach mehr sinn
und wir haben es auch gedacht wir machen
so krasse challenges jede folge dann
können wir nicht einfach noch zusätzlich
ein gigantisches mod pack haben weil es
wäre einfach zu viel für eine folge dass
wir dann erleben genau minecraft maut
ist nämlich wie ihr das eventuell schon
wisst runtergebrochen auf zehn folgen
das heißt es läuft genau bis zum
jahresende wobei es regnet auch nochmals
ich wollte gerade fragen wo du bist und
jetzt wird hier wieder düstere stimmung
kommen wir wieder zu dem wasser wo du
gerade den shader angeguckt dass da was
wollte ich dann gerade sagen bin ich
dumm bist du hey hey wünsche und ich
wieder zu haben
hast du überhaupt genug essen ich habe
essen schon geholt ja ich habe auch
schon holz geholt ich bin auch schon
sachen gemacht
das sieht ja so hammer aus mit den
pfützen guckt euch das an leute was
die hammer ist das bitte mit dem shader
alles sofort aufhören zu reden zehn
liegestütze sofort ist mir jetzt ganz
egal was du gerade mal ich hab gerade
deswegen gemacht als wenn ich jetzt
schon wieder zehn mache vielleicht werde
ich luca jetzt mal ein bisschen schon
weil meine erste folge müssen wir
natürlich auch ein bisschen was schaffen
was auch richtig cool ist bei minecraft
ausfindig bei wago waren wir immer so
begrenzt bzw
haben sogar einen strike bekommen weil
wir geschnitten haben das ist natürlich
auch alles rechtmäßig passiert also es
war klar ich hab geschnitten deswegen
hab ich ein streit bekommen aber hier
ist es halt so dass ist das projekt von
maximal wir können machen was wir wollen
wir können schneiden was wir wollen
ich könnte einfach mal den server
verlassen ohne dass ich jetzt irgendwas
bekomme oder irgendwie eine strafe
bekommen du bist jetzt gebannt
das war es vom video war der damen und
herren ich bin aber auf jeden fall heißt
es fakt und ich hab dich schon wieder
verloren max dreh dich einfach um
da bist du das ist so krass für diesen
shader wird man wird es so das ist so
laufen mal weg ja okay doch man sie dann
aber man sieht ein halt nicht so gut ich
bin auf eine fährt luca wieso bist auf
dem fahrrad
wir können uns ja mal den allerersten
verschlag woge heute nacht überleben
bauen oder ich bin schon dabei sehr gut
eigentlich noch steine pharma war
barrios vermissen denn max du schon
wieder weg ich bin direkt vor unserer
ecke da wo ich alles aufgestellt
naturhaus so die ganze zeit ob es sieht
so geil aus mit dem shader ohne spaß
edith regentropfen plätschernder so
drauf gehabt die leute oft genug gehört
dass windräder toll findest luca was für
technische erfolg fortschritt wieso hast
du schon wieder ein archiv mitbekommen
was hast du diesmal gemacht als mit
stein irgendwas gemacht oder einstein
spitzhacke ja gut manchmal auch es geht
auf jeden fall leicht voran wie gesagt
wir hatten wirklich erst vorgehabt das
ganze mit hexe zu machen allerdings wie
schon die marke schon gesagt hat es wäre
halt einfach wirklich zu viel gewesen
mach zehn liegestütze ich war gerade was
erzählen egal was jetzt in liegestütze
[Musik]
das wichtigste wenn man die gestützte
macht aber wo war ich fast stehen
geblieben
wir hatten wirklich erst zu den waffen
vorsicht wie viele herzen hasst du 3 wir
hatten erst gedacht wirklich meine texte
zu machen aber da gibt es ja so viele
sachen und textet nicht kennt das ist
einfach ein riesiges ein riesiger
zusammenschluss zusammen verbund von
ganz vielen mods und dann sitzt also
viele sachen und dann musste man extra
version haben und vor allem auch dadurch
dass wir diese ganze challenges haben
zum beispiel in der ersten folge ich
jetzt gerade geht es noch mit den
liegestützen haben wir haben bald auch
noch so challenges wie wo wir
beispielsweise teilweise mal hände über
kreuz haben oder max muss zum beispiel
der nächsten folge war sah wie essen
also wenn richtig scharfe frucht süße
soße luca ich hab gerade eben zwei
sachen gesehen die ganz wichtig wären da
vorne hatte ich gesehen gibt es ein
schnee bio das wäre cool für den winter
effekt und so aber hier vorne ist mit
nils b das heißt wenn wir da vielleicht
eine disco finden dann hätten wir für
immer genug essen das heißt wir sind
hier quasi in der nähe von einem pilz b
um was ganz geil wäre bezüglich essen
und ein studium was ganz geil wäre
bezüglich winter noch nein es wird nacht
ich habe ich habe nur drei wolle
wir wollen es machen einer geht vom
server und der andere steht nein keiner
geht vom server max dann machst du jetzt
zehn liegestütze jetzt ja da muss ich
mich beschützen nehmen
du machst dir liegestütze ist mir egal
was in der zeit mit ihr passiert das ist
so geil leute ich weiß vielleicht sagen
einige mit dem schiller ja okay so ist
ein bisschen düster oder so aber mit der
fackel
das versetzt ein richtig in seine kasse
was ist das hier das ist das was für
monster hier egal wie kommt sofort für
nicht nur bei den shader schwärmen und
du machst du das halbe leben gehöre ich
habe so eine dicke höhle hier gefunden
ich hab so einen dicken dicke meiner
hose
in krieg und krieg in kryta ok ok ok
jetzt ist natürlich gift und shader
warte ja ich hoffe dass ich muss mal die
fackel hinsetzen damit ihr den so ein
bisschen sehe da kommt der kripo an ich
will jetzt natürlich nicht so kassing
was kaputt machen in dieser welt läuft
vor allem nicht störe luca luca kehrt
den creepy sie macht zehn liegestütze
wie sowieso letzte liegestütz nein was
jetzt der ligister challenge jetzt
sofort junge bitte nicht ich habe dass
ich habe das was hab ich schon hier und
das extra so eine kleine packung weiße
schaf ist und luca will mich jetzt
fertig machen na super
[Musik]
ich habe fünf volle wir müssen noch eine
einzige finden dann können wir
wenigstens mal die nacht überleben indem
wir schlafen hier vorne kommt nämlich
jetzt die große schlucht glaube da
können wir auf jeden fall schon mal
richtig gut was finden aber ich habe
noch alles okay dann können wir schlafen
geh einfach zu schlucht wollen wir hier
stark mutter sterben werden
wir probieren es einfach mal aus mauth
trifft natürlich nebeneinander ich setze
die fackel dahin die ich noch unter der
fackel beziehungsweise in der fackel
thomas j das wird mir ganz viel zu viel
action leute an dieser stelle würde ich
sagen ich beende diese erste folge
minecraft mords an dieser stelle wir
sind gerade bei 30 minuten der overtime
ich hoffe ich kann das kann jetzt auf
eine humane länge runter kürzen denn
euch diese erste voll gemeinschaft aus
gefallen hat will ich 400.000 millionen
doch dieses video
sonst findet ihr hier eine 2d
eingeblendet wenn er darauf könnte ihm
einen kanal abonnieren ist free
kostenlos nice und man wird ein besserer
mensch dadurch habe ich irgendwann mal
gelesen in dem magazin hier findet
irgendein anderes video eingeblendet ist
locker auch richtig scheiße max kann als
in der beschreibung da findet ihr dann
die nächste folge morgen
[Musik]
ciao